you touched on the fact that we've lost
Bob Saget Gilbert Gottfried Norm
McDonald all in a relatively short
period of time yeah it almost feels like
a conspiracy I mean it it these really
uh really uniquely talented people
um and I you were wonderful at the norm
tribute that the Netflix Festival had
that was great oh thanks I hosted that
Memorial is really special afternoon it
was um but it does uh you know I've been
thinking about it lately because I knew
like a new Norm better I think I knew
the Gilbert Gilbert used to do tons of
bits for us over the years and what I
remember about Gilbert was he was the
most
um the difference between backstage
Gilbert and on-air Gilbert was the
largest difference I think I've seen in
a performer he'd be so quiet
he just wanted to take food from the
craft Services
put it in his pockets and get it home to
his rent controlled apartment like that
that's what he mostly wanted to do so
odd but he was so yeah he uh I loved him
but he's so sweet so sweet and
he was one of the first uh when I first
got out of school and was in New York I
went to a comedy club and I barely knew
who he was and the crowd was they said
listen to him and Gilbert Gottfried he
came on stage and he went thank you
thank you please please no thank you
please sits too much sit thank you and
then he kept doing that for maybe 11
minutes and people at my table were
getting I didn't know them I was just
sitting in but people at my table were
getting mad they were getting mad and
then there's silence and he's going I
beg of you please please it's too much
how can I reciprocate
and I was dying my job fell off I was
crying and then of course he got the
crowd back again but I thought that the
balls on that guy to do that he was one
of a kind talk about Fearless
um
I I I I spoke at his funeral and and and
and one thing that I I said that day
that you know he he did this joke on my
uh Netflix bumping mic special uh about
skull [ __ ] his dead grandma
that Old Chestnut yeah no now I'm at his
funeral and I'm looking at his wife and
his he has kids but a 13 year old and a
15 year old and he had this whole other
side to him yeah he was a great dad and
and and I love his kids I took his son
to see Billy Crystal's uh amazing new
musical uh the other day
um and I know that both sides of Gilbert
so here I am at his funeral and I'm
talking about how Gilbert's comedy is
fearless and subversive but yet he was
so lovable he could get us to laugh at a
joke about skull [ __ ] a dead person
and I looked at his coffin and said not
so funny now
[Laughter]
did that come over but we buried him
with a soundproof coffin
he was very loud and uh a wonderful
wonderful uh uh uh person a unique
person
um a one-of-a-kind type of individual
and he will be missed